hey guys chastity here and I'm with Jeff
Palumbo the Gaming Engagement Manager at
Lenovo Legion and we're going to talk
about e3 2017 in general PC gaming and
Lenovo Legion the line of hardware from
Lenovo for gamers yes that's right
that's awesome thanks for having me I
appreciate it being here yes definitely
so Lenovo is fairly very young in the
gaming space so why did they decide to
get into gaming about two years ago we
started designing everything around
gaming we didn't have gaming PC's who
had multimedia pcs but what we found is
that a lot of our community was actually
asking for gaming they're you know and
they said well we have other competitors
and they said why don't you do gaming
PC's so we really looked into it and
found that due to the fact that our
distribution model and how big we are as
a PC manufacturer in general kind of
lent us to getting right into it and
being a competitor right off the bat and
we definitely take a different approach
to gaming which I'm pur will talk about
so and after two years we're cranking it
out and really making some waves which
is great exciting so PC gaming is really
big right now why do you think it's a
good time to be a PC gamer and also to
jump into PC gaming if you haven't
started yet well I think over time it's
been easier I think you know a decade or
two ago it was very difficult you had to
load to disk there's software problems
and now they've made it more mainstream
where you really can load digitally any
game you really want steam made a huge
bonus to that and we have something like
reman gaming which is a competitor
there's so it's easy to get digital
content now and to play it and I think
the PCs are just so much more powerful
so you see that with a lot of streaming
specifically I think the the streaming
market really helped a lot of people
want to do something else like they'd be
gaming but now like oh well I can stream
and maybe I can make some money off of
it so the dynamic of what twitch has
kind of brought to gaming in general has
really helped now you have mixer and in
the mix you know for lack of a better
term and yeah thank you I appreciate
that and I think that is really what is
going to make a big difference is just
how acceptable and how usable PCs are
and how much you can do with them which
on at the moment great for us blow away
any console you see awesome that's
really exciting so let's talk about
lenovo légion so tell me more about how
these hardware pieces
to be so again we we kind of started
with multimedia and when we launched our
first products two years ago our goal
was to actually have more of a community
oriented segment so we want to make sure
that yes we had product but we were
doing is we were listening to our
community on what they wanted it's great
we're probably never going to have 50
SKUs like some of our competitors have
we're going to have ton but they're the
ten that our community actually wants to
purchase and use their specialized for
what they are asking that's right yeah
so for instance we had a Y 700 laptop
last year and the feedback was people
liked it but they wanted two things they
wanted it lighter and they wanted to
make sure that the price point was down
a little bit more so that is why we have
a Y 520 right now it actually came from
the community and we do market research
and things of that nature what that does
is that just solidifies what they're
actually asking and to my knowledge
we're really the only PC company that
does that we care so much about what our
community wants that's what we're going
to build next that's great
so you mentioned the Lenovo Legion Y 520
laptop can you tell me more about that
yep so it is under six pounds it's very
slick very sleek it has an i7 7700 it
has a you can either get a GTX time 50
times 50 TI or a 1060 and we wanted to
make sure that the price point was
really good
so I think right now you can get it for
850 dollars or less so it really fits in
that price point we had a lot of people
from college that may not have
disposable income yet and that was their
biggest thing they wanted something you
could use from school but their main
entertainment value is gaming so we
wanted something that was powerful
enough to game but at that price point
would that they felt like they could
actually use and they can use it usually
through college and then at that point
they can transfer up to something else a
catch-all for everything you need but
especially gaming yeah well yeah
especially I mean that's definitely that
depend all you want yes for sure and we
focused on that and we passed it by some
people we had under NDA that are our
gamers that are just community members
and they're like this is what we want
great and we knew those up so there's
also the Lenovo Legion y 720 that's
correct yeah can you tell me about that
yeah so that has a little more bells and
whistles it's a little more expensive
but the screens are the same it still
has a GTX 960 in it but what it has it
has Dolby Atmos is the first laptop
they come with Dolby Atmos and that's
fantastic the sound quality on that is
ridiculous it also allows you to sync
your Xbox one controller directly to
your Xbox account which not a lot of
people have and then it also has what we
call the LeNoble entertainment hub which
is the new software we're working on
that actually allows you to go through
Green Man gaming and load content or
preload content that you have and it
turns it almost into an upscaled virtual
reality so it's something that we're
working on we're going to continue
working on it's brand-new
so those things together plus it has
some lighting effects
you'd really want it's a little bit
heavier but it can crank out everything
and you can use it for VR so let's talk
about desktops so tell me more about the
Y 720 cube from Lenovo Legion yeah we
actually came out with that because
while people loved our Y 900 series
which was very upgradable it's just a
regular desktop what people were asking
for is something closer to a small form
factor the reason for that is because
desktops take up quite a bit of space so
what we did is we designed the Y 720
cube in order to kind of put it wherever
you want it is a little bit bigger than
what your typical small form factor
would be but you can pick it up it's
actually pretty light and you can
upgrade it I think that's one of the
biggest things that is while it does
also sync to your Xbox controller
because we have that integration you can
upgrade it how you want part of the
legion's big piece is we don't want you
to buy a shell of something and feel
like in two years that you have to buy
another one we want you to use that for
as long as you want try to upgrade it as
much as possible and when you're ready
come on back to us we'll have something
new for you awesome
so I know you're into gaming I am so if
I were to get my Lenovo Legion Y 720
cube what should I play on it uh well if
you have the ability to play
battlegrounds what a fantastic game that
is right now man there's a whole bunch
of stuff coming out here that is amazing
but if you were to load anything I mean
overwatch everybody plays people love
hearthstone and blizzards hard to beat
they do such a good job let's talk about
e3 27 so what games are you excited
about that you can possibly play on
lenovo Legion products destiny 2 is
probably number one because the stuff it
was so Console heavy that not it really
was in the PC realm and the PC community
is just loving it and we've already been
asked multiple times can you do
something with them can you
something they want exclusives and stuff
like that so we'll be talking to
activated in the future and see what we
can do at the same time you know call
duty world of war - is there there's
some great stuff coming out with Ubisoft
like skull and bones or Assassin's Creed
origins is coming out Far Cry 5 is
coming out so there's really a ton of
fantastic content that is coming out
within the next year that I think our
pcs can easily handle on high and ultra
settings just by plugging it and playing
it I think that's one of the biggest
pieces we have is we want to make sure
that we're transparent with our
community so when we do gameplay videos
or we do something that's on YouTube or
we're streaming anything that you see is
exactly what you get that's our biggest
value we don't opt if we don't optimize
differently in overclock to make it look
better you plug it in you play it looks
just what like we do fantastic and
lastly what is the game that you're most
excited about playing out of III 2017
well I pretty sure I will lose part of
my life on destiny to see if thieves
looks awesome that is it looks like a
lot of fun yeah I was actually with your
friends and that that's just it I think
the the gaming world is lacking a really
great MMO right now I think yeah world
of warcraft and things like that have
been around for a while I think
everybody is going those are going to
stay but nothing's been so fun is what
see if thieves could be yeah and yup and
I'm married with kids so I either have
to find time to play after or get my son
to play with me and I think that's how
we're gonna get it done
awesome well Jeff thank you so much for
being here thank you you guys appreciate
and for all things III stick with
GameSpot
[Music]
you
[Music]